Hello, Sienna,
Hello Conan, how are you?
I'm doing very well now .
You look stunning and,
and you're just the whole
this looks like a
Christmas card right now.
You're beautiful.
And your background is beautiful.
Yeah. I'm almost matching your background
which is extremely festive as well.
I need some colored lights.
You've inspired me.
Well, you seem to be in a lovely home.
I'm in an abandoned theater in Hollywood.
That's overrun with rats.
So...
(laughs)
You talk about your crew that way?
Now you look, you look very
like you're in the Christmas spirit.
Are you excited about Christmas right now?
I am as much as one can be excited
about anything this year.
Yes
yeah
yes! Christmas.
Tell me, because I know that
was not convincing, you know?
And, and, and you're an actress
and you couldn't pull that off for 2020,
which ,
( laughs)
( Mumbling)
Yeah.
Did...
I'm curious.
Do you, I've always thought
that the perfect Christmas
would be in London because it
it seems it's Charles Dickens.
It's the perfect place
to celebrate Christmas.
Is it?
What are the traditions?
What will you be doing on Christmas day?
That feels very British to you?.
I can outdo your London
with my 16th century thatched cottage
in the Dickensian town of West Wickham.
I've just told the world my address.
Not that anyone cares,
(laughs)
and it it's a Hobbit house.
It sort of looks like
something out of middle earth
and I'll sit by the fire
and I will drink red wine
and I will be in pajamas
and they will eat.
That sounds fantastic.
I have to say that
sounds absolutely lovely.
Am I can't believe you live in a
you live in a thatched cottage.
That just makes me so happy.
It sounds like a fairy tale.
It actually is.
It really is.
It's a fairy tale.
What are the kind of, you
know, I've always heard that
in Europe, every country has
their own little traditions.
I don't know what you do.
What are there any
traditions that you have?
Because in America we
just opened the presence
and then we insult each other.
What do you do in, in London or growing
up? Know there there's
certain games you play
or ways to pass the time?
In England, we open the booze
before the presence,
Nice.
that also leads to catastrophic fights
but we do sit around the kitchen table
and we play a game called name and a hat.
Have you ever played that game?
No.
You put, everybody puts
like five famous names
of famous people, dead or
alive into a hat fold it up
and you're on two teams.
(sniffing)
and you pull a name...
I have got a cold its not going
Its okay, that's okay.
pull a name out of the hat.
And I have to describe who the
is without saying the name.
And as the rounds go on,
you just get one word.
So by the time you've played three rounds
you could say" walking stick",
they go "Winston Churchill"
because you've done walking
stick, cigar, whatever.
Right.
So the first round you'd
say walking sticks ,cigar
(indistinct)
Yeah, yeah.
World war two.
If you got my name, what would you say?
if you got counted?
( indistinct)
Funny.
Nice.
Thank you.
Handsome.
Proactive.
Charming.
(laughs)
Yeah
Sienna!
No one would get it if you said that,
(laughs)
You need to say, ah
you need to say thin lips, aging badly
and people will go "Conan"
And then you, yeah,
that's the way to do it.